♪♪
-Hey!
[ Laughs ]
[ Laughter ]
It's time for "Corrections."
We'll just jump right into it,
you guys.
We had a joke in "A Closer Look"
about a note,
the sort of note you would pass
in high school,
and we spelled "later"
L-8-- the number 8 -- T-E-R.
Many of you pointed out
you wouldn't need the "T,"
'cause the 8 has a "T" in it.
It would be L-8-E-R, would be
the correct way to spell that.
A lot of you said that.
We have learned our lesson,
and, you know,
just a reminder to anyone
who wants to be that nit-picky,
you can go 8 a bag of 6.
Is that right?
[ Laughter ]
There's no sailor
in the Village People,
but this is a weird gray area
because we only said it
as Donald Trump,
and I do think Donald Trump
would think there was a sailor
in the Village People because of
the song "In the Navy."
He would hear that
and then just assume
that maybe all of them
were also sailors,
as sort of a second job.
People can have two jobs.
Also, someone wrote,
according to the cop --
this is something
a jackal wrote --
according to the cop,
"YMCA" is just about the YMCA.
Which is probably what,
you know, they told him
because he was the cop.
[ Laughter ]
You know he said, "Hey, guys,
before we record this,
I just want to make sure...
there's no subtext to this,
right?
'Cause, you know, I got a lot
of friends on the force."
Also, it's crazy.
So nice to be a Republican,
because Trump just walks out
to gay anthems all the time,
knowing he's just safe
from criticism.
No Democratic politician
would risk
walking out to "YMCA"
or "Macho Man."
They would think they'd get
attacked on Fox News
for -- for weeks!
He's got the -- Donald Trump's
got the same playlist
as a Pride parade.
[ Laughter ]
Just walking out --
♪ I'm coming out ♪
[ Laughs ]
[As Trump] I think I walk out
to "Born This Way,"
then I talk about how the
American family is under attack,
and then I exit
to "It's Raining Men."
[Normal voice]
We made a joke about a Prius,
but in the graphic
it was a Subaru Outback.
So of course, I went down
to Graphics and I said,
"Do you guys know
I wanted a Prius
and you gave me an Outback?"
And they said,
"Ohh, noooo.
Are you gonna take us out back?"
[ Muttering ]
Christ.
We mentioned a law firm
in the Vatican,
a commercial for a law firm
in the Vatican
where you dial 1-800.
And it was pointed out that
the country code in the Vatican
is 379.
So you would have to dial 379
if you wanted to call
a lawyer in the Vatican.
And this is interesting.
All the attorneys in the Vatican
are defense attorneys.
[ Laughter ]
Okay.
So, this was something
that was sent in...
And this is very hard
for me to read.
Because I don't wear glasses.
Oh, there it is. Okay.
So...
We were talking about
how I mixed up Michelangelo
and Da Vinci,
and I sort of said, "Yeah,
but without their bandanas,
how can you tell them apart?"
And someone said, "You said
you couldn't tell them apart
without their bandanas.
I get that this is a joke
about the Ninja Turtles.
However, there is no
Da Vinci Ninja Turtle.
Only a Leonardo.
So the joke falls apart there."
I would argue
it fell apart far earlier.
[ Laughter ]
Let's see.
Oh, so we talked about
Edvard -- I said "Moonch."
It's pronounced Edvard "Monk."
Edvard Munch.
It's a "K" sound.
And...
And then I did some reading
about Edvard Munch.
He went to the Royal School
of Art and Design in Norway.
He studied in Paris and Berlin.
He suffered from OCD,
which was very --
which actually made him
very helpful to the local
police department
that would go to him
for his help solving crimes.
They would say, "Get me Munch."
[ Light laughter ]
He was never married.
Never married,
and had a girlfriend.
And when he showed her --
it was a heartbreaking story.
When he showed her...
[ Laughs ]
When he showed her The Scream,
you know, she just looked at it
and said -- [ Laughs ]
She goes, "Oh, so you're
the biggest --
You're the -- Ohh --
[ Laughs ]
She's like, "Oh, you're the most
famous Norwegian painter?"
♪ That don't impress me, Munch ♪
[ Laughter ]
There was a musical
about his life.
[ Laughing ] It's...
It's true, there was
a musical about his life.
Came out recently.
This is true.
Called "Dear Edvard."
And critics say --
critics said,
"If you meant to buy a ticket
for 'Dear Evan Hansen,'
this is the worst
possible outcome."
[ Light laughter ]
"Oh, so much screaming."
I told a joke about
cats with arthritis,
how there was a new treatment
for cats with arthritis,
which replaced the old treatment
of a brick in a burlap sack.
A lot of cat lovers
were in the comments section
and very upset.
One went so far to say,
"Can you even imagine?
Can you imagine telling
that joke about a dog?"
And I would never do that.
You know,
because people like dogs.
[ Laughter ]
We said if there was -- if there
had been voter fraud in Vermont,
Rudy would have done
a press conference
at Burlington Coat Factory.
I was told it's Burlington
Township, New Jersey,
is why it's the Burlington
Coat Factory.
But I think Rudy --
again, artistic license.
I don't think Rudy knows that.
So I think we can
get away with that one.
We also, though, talked about
Rudy breaking into...
...the Shawshank prison,
that he would do the reverse.
Andy Dufresne would break out,
and Rudy would break in,
and he would be happy
because there would be,
you know, a bed and a toilet
and a poster of Rita Hayworth.
Again, multiple jackals
pointed out that
when Andy Dufresne escaped, it
wasn't a Rita Hayworth poster,
it was a Raquel Welch poster.
And one person who said that
followed up by saying,
"I guess you could say
what I've just given you
is a Shawshank correction."
Leave it to the professionals,
guys.
[ Laughter ]
Because that...
don't impress me Munch.
[ Laughs ]
Oh, so last week's correction,
I talked about a mistake I made,
how I said...
I referred to someone
as a Chewbacca.
Chewbacca is the name.
Wookie is the species.
And then right after that,
right after I clarified that,
I referred to a vampire
as a Dracula.
And many of you said,
"Dude, you just made
the same mistake twice.
The mistake you just corrected,
you did again."
It's almost like
I did it on purpose.
[ Light laughter ]
Oh, we had a joke about --
there was a tree
named after Leo DiCaprio,
and then we said
it's now dating a sapling.
And we put up a picture,
but the picture was a seedling,
and I wanted to apologize
and I said I wanted to apologize
to all the tree enthusiast--
tree enthusiasts.
And I was told that a word
for tree enthusiasts
is a dendrophile.
And if you like seedlings,
it's pendrophile.
[ Laughter ]
And if you want to --
if you are a pendrophile,
who's looking to talk to some,
you know, like-minded people
just -- you want
to pick up the phone.
It's, uh, country code 379.
[ Laughter ]
Did a joke about
the Olive Garden
and said, "When you're here,
you're family."
That's not Olive Garden's
slogan anymore.
Shoemaker, do you know
whose slogan it is now?
Jimmy Fallon got the rights
to that slogan.
Do you even remember that?
He got the rights to it.
They stopped using it.
The Olive Garden
stopped using it.
Fallon reached out, said,
"Can we use it?"
And they gave it to him,
in 2013.
And so at first I was like,
well, I never got my own slogan,
you know, from a restaurant.
But, you know,
he's "The Tonight Show,"
and we're "Late Night,"
but then I did the math --
that was when he had
"Late Night."
So, you know,
I marched up to the brass.
You know I don't mind
talking to the brass
when I feel as though
I've been slighted.
And I said, you know,
"I want one."
So, you know.
That's -- The problem,
though, of course,
is then you can't be picky
when they get you one.
But we do have a new slogan.
And you'll see it
the next time you see a promo.
If you see like a promo of ours
in "SNL"
this week after "Update,"
probably right before
good nights, maybe...
It'll say, you know, it'll say
my guests and whatever,
and it'll say, you know,
watch this week
on "Late Night
with Seth Meyers,"
no one out-pizzas the Hut.
[ Laughter ]
I can't be picky.
They said
it could've been worse.
I guess the other option
was, "We speak fish."
It's Long --
[ Laughs ]
It's Long John S--
That's Long --
[ Laughs ]
Thomas Jefferson.
We talked about Thomas Jefferson
and inventions.
I said he invented
the polygraph,
which was when you --
It wasn't a lie detector,
but it's two pens attached
so that when you --
you write in duplicate.
I guess pantagraph
is technically
how you would say that.
And you know, when you look up--
'cause I did, you know,
I try to do my research
before "Corrections"
'cause obviously I take it
deeply seriously.
And a lot of --
some people say Thomas Jefferson
invented the dumbwaiter
or the pedometer,
but the more you read,
the more you realize
he just, like, went --
they had those things in France
and then he came back
and was like,
"Look what I invented," but he
just like, bought it there.
Which sounds like something.
That does sound like something.
Like, we all respect
Thomas Jefferson so much,
but that is definitely a thing
you would think
that Trump would have done,
just like gone abroad
and, like, come back...
Like, gone to the Middle East
and been like --
[As Trump]
I've got a new bread.
It's a circular flatbread.
It's a pouch.
[Normal voice] Also, one thing
he brought from Naples --
it was purchased for
Thomas Jefferson in Naples,
or as Shoemaker says --
[Italian accent] "Napoli."
[ Laughs ]
[ Gibberish ]
[Normal voice]
It was a macaroni machine,
and a lot of people say that
Thomas Jefferson popularized
macaroni and cheese
in the United States
because he got from Naples
this macaroni machine.
But, again, he did not invent
macaroni and cheese.
I think his best --
I think we can all agree
Thomas Jefferson's
best invention
was when he had
to invent an excuse
for why Sally Hemings' kids
had his eyes.
[ Laughter ]
'Cause Martha walked in
and was like,
"I have a question."
He was like,
"I have two questions --
Do you like macaroni
and cheese?"
[ Laughter ]
Well, I feel like
this was really fun.
And, you know...
I really wanted to do the "that
don't impress me Munch" thing
when I thought it was "Munch."
I think it would've gone better.
But I also wanted
to get it right.
Um...alright.
[ Sighs ]
[ Laughs ]
Bye. [ Laughs ]